hurry up
all right
oh my God okay so you guys you're both
so incredible in this movie I absolutely
loved it we do delve into their family a
little bit in this film which I
absolutely love so let's have a little
family time what do you think the
brothers are watching on family movie
night oh
Karate Kid oh yeah you know what I bet
they're big Karate Kid I bet you they
are yeah yeah absolutely
okay what's on the playlist because
there's some great music in this some
great Throwbacks and yeah really great
mute not only music that's sentimental
from the game but also some really great
needle drop moments we have some awesome
soundtrack really great soundtrack yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so what are you
adding to the playlist what do the guys
have on their Walkman well it would have
to always sentimental music from the era
that I played Super Mario Brothers which
was like the late 80s so I'm going to be
getting some white snake on there I
think Luigi's listening to a lot of
self-help tapes you know just trying to
like you know just that's good trying to
like you know meditate and relax a
little bit yeah all right who's the
favorite Child I think Luigi I think
Luigi I think he's a little bit like
more gonna do what Mom and Dad want yeah
and Mario
Mario's gonna take some risks and then
Luigi's gotta you know be like
Mario's gonna do it anyway and then it's
like you know you're gonna this is crazy
man you can't you can't be doing that
but
that's Mario okay and last one you both
you have this dream of being plumbers we
love the commercial who's the better
plumber for real maybe on the surface
level it's Mario but who for real is the
better plumber between the two of you
we've talked we've talked a little bit
about this and we've determined that
it's probably Charlie yeah weirdly I'm
okay with like a plumbing situation but
don't ask me for any kind of carpentry
or construction I'm terrible at it but
if something's like leaking or running
I'm like Oh my brain knows how to fix
that yeah
the toilets
he
gets he fixes him yeah so in that way
it's a good partnership so this film
what it did for me it's such a great
film but there are so many worlds you
could explore in the what you called
Chris in our last conversation the Mario
Cinematic Universe so yes two favorites
are Wario and Waluigi and I'm wondering
who the two of you would cast and would
you want to team up against those two in
a future iteration oh my gosh who would
we cast
probably ourselves to do both voices
right you know if we're smart we're
gonna yeah we're gonna cast ourselves if
we're being generous yes I think we're
gonna cast uh you know Danny DeVito and
Dustin Hoffman yeah
oh I like that yeah it's really good
really nice I like how you pulled that
one out maybe you know maybe we're just
gonna we're gonna think outside the box
here we're gonna throw Meryl Streep in
there yeah yeah she can do it all she
can
she can do it all so why not she'll
probably wouldn't be nominated for an
Oscar for it too yeah she probably will
and she would win
so now that you've had some had some
spend together I know you were in London
you've had time to actually grow out
because I know you voice record on your
own but Chris what makes Charlie the
perfect Luigi and Charlie what makes
Chris the perfect Mario I would say he's
got a a tone and an energy in his voice
that just uh alone without any
affectations is in itself really great
for Luigi
um you know I think he played the video
game as a youngster and his sister was
always Mario so he was always forced to
be Luigi so he was like you know she she
was kind of Mr miyaging him a little bit
he didn't he didn't know at the time but
she was training him for this and uh so
that's why he's the perfect uh Luigi
yeah and like listen this guy here uh
and he's done it time and time again can
carry a movie uh which not everyone can
do uh so you know you can put him in the
Lego movie or uh Guardians of the Galaxy
uh or or these other big franchises
Jurassic whatever it is and they you
keep churning out great movie after
great movie so if you're going to want
to put an iconic character like Mario in
someone's hands you want to put in
someone's hands that you know can can
execute a a big fantastic hit movie and
I think you did it so I'm super proud of
this guy I'll work with him any day
that was such brotherly love that was
like low energy yeah go ahead and cry
man go ahead cry it out you know go
ahead and cry I love you it's all right
I keep an onion in my pockets he cries
like every
awesome thank you so much for your time
and by the way Keegan told me that toad
is in love with peach so watch out Mario
in the next film oh dang okay that
sounds like something he would say
yeah
you got the cat box
oh my I'm sorry okay now you die first
of all I was looking for something that
you had said online and I found a
picture of you from 2016 you dressed up
as Mario for Halloween I did actually
were you miscast stuff that was me
trying to get the roll it was lost
clearly they didn't Mr Chris Mill and
Audrey missed that one
no but for real why why do you think you
were better cast as Donkey Kong in this
film because you were phenomenal I'm not
a role model like Mario is you know
that's too much pressure I think for me
I think I think more of a maybe uh
someone who's more in a moral gray area
suits me a little better
that's firmly we're Donkey Kong lies
well he does because he's been seen as a
hero and as a villain we we can call him
an anti-hero but in this film especially
he's very famous you know in his world
and he's really feeling himself so how
did you channel the anti-hero I'm super
famous I love myself energy because that
seems like the opposite of you it wasn't
that hard
living it every day I rolled out of bed
that's how
um
yeah it was uh it wasn't that hard it
was pretty funny uh yeah honestly mostly
what I thought would be funny was if he
hated Mario like that to me was the big
was like I just wanted a joke
I'm always just looking for like what is
the joke in a scene to scene basis like
you know the like what is something you
can play like a dynamic that can like
live on throughout the course of a movie
that the audience understands the setup
and the parameters of it and
um yeah so yeah this idea that Donkey
Kong is kind of this uh you know kind of
cocky you know uh guy who really just
wants his father's attention and and has
to like team up with this idiot that he
hates in order to get it um that to me
was a a funny Dynamic yeah well he does
want his dad's attention his dad kind of
just tells him what to do and he's
played by Fred Armisen chocolate you
talked about him a little bit the last
time I talked to talk about that energy
like how does Kong feel about that and
how do you feel about that I mean Fred
Emerson's telling you what to do
you know no one wants that
of all the people you don't want to tell
you what to do Fred Armisen high on the
list
I uh yeah it's a good you know I think
it's funny that they like there are all
these Kong figures and it is you know is
it from a writing standpoint it's very
clever how they found a way to kind of
create an intuitive narrative using
these things from a video game that like
you know there was like a suggested
story there but there was not a lot
there to start with you know it is
pretty brilliant what they did I know
it's actually interesting because I
actually also found out searching the
internet your dog is named Zelda and you
actually did say when you were younger
you were playing the games you really
did want to be in this world so what
would you see as a gamer as somebody
who's a fan a future Nintendo movie what
do you think you'd like to see I mean is
it obvious is it Zelda or is there
somebody else that you'd like to see
their film get on you know put on screen
as a writer too Zelda would be maybe I'm
not the person to bring that to life I
think but uh yeah I've been I bet I
would I think a Metroid movie would be
cool I I always liked that game and I
always thought that was a cool character
I love it could you and if you can talk
a little bit I mean fans have been
anticipating The Showdown and they've
showed it a little bit of it in the
trailer
um the showdown between Donkey Kong and
Mario so if you can without spoilers
sort of breakdown watch it back after
lending your voice to it and sort of
your impression because it's such an
epic scene it's actually my favorite
scene in the movie
um it was really cool and I remember
seeing like a very early animatic of
kind of the introduction of the
character and and being instantly so
excited that they were like just
delivering you know on everything I
think you would hope a Donkey Kong's
fight with Mario would possibly have and
I think there's a lot of like again it's
one of those things where like you don't
want the audience's kind of like
projected version of it to be better
than the thing that you were giving them
in the movie and and and I think that's
what this movie does very well is
actually like deliver better than you
expected versions of these kind of
settings and these sequences and these
these set pieces you know Keegan told me
toad is actually secretly in love with
peach we know Mario probably is is Kong
also in love with Peach is everybody
just in love with peach Kong's in love
with himself
[Laughter]
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're incredible hi you look
amazing as always and actually my very
first question for you is about fashion
okay you are a fashion icon every time
you step out on a carpet people go crazy
I want you to break down Peach's style
for us is she a style icon hell yeah
absolutely and I think that if you asked
anybody on the street they would say the
same thing I do have a personal pension
for the motorcycle outfit it's so good
and I do think that that Anvil is
required that's a you know you you need
the ax you need the ax with it it's it
completes the outfit so of so all the
outfits that we see in this film is that
the one that you're wearing in real life
if we're doing like a live action on the
street version that is a thousand
percent my favorite outfit for sure so I
wanted to talk to you about uh just this
version of peach that we see in this
film this is only the second time she
has a fire flower which is very symbolic
of her power and her skills in this film
and I want them to know because I know
you have Mad Max coming up is she
channeling furiosa or spuriosa
channeling Peach and can you compare
their fighting styles honestly it's the
weirdest thing I never thought that the
two characters in my career that had
like a lot in common would be furious
and Princess Peach so that's like quite
surreal for me and funnily enough I was
working on both of them at the same time
because I did a lot of Voice work in
Australia
um yeah compare their fighting styles
I think furiosa is more
um
dogged in the sense that she's just like
straight in full force like go for it
with peaches uh I think she adds a bit
more flourishes to what she's doing she
likes a she likes a flip
she likes to make it look uh attractive
does our Peach
she does a very good job I love her very
elegant she is very elegant it's funny
that you're doing the voice recording
like I wonder if Peach sort of bled into
furio so like when you would go on set
if you had to like change the voice up
and be like oh my gosh what am I
I want to talk about there's a line in
the in the film that you say that I
think is my favorite line in the film
and it's there's a huge Universe out
there with a lot of galaxies and it gets
everybody of course excited about what
could be the future I think people would
be very excited to see a Super Mario
Galaxy as the fact that you're now an
Aficionado which world would you like to
see explored in a future movie and which
which world would you like to see peach
in oh
oh I think I think I'd love to go
underwater I think that would be super
fun like I just I'd love to see how
that's animated I think they've done
such a beautiful job of creating
paintings out of every frame in this
movie like it's genuinely just beautiful
it's the most beautiful animated movie
I've ever seen so I'd love to see how
those characters are drawn in water I
think that'd be pretty cool
um maybe there's like um
a Mario Sunshine Universe where they're
on an island
no I'm thinking about specifically Mario
Kart the names escaping me right now but
like the track is both under water and
you kind of like go all around yeah it's
really cool you just got me very excited
for that I did not know I did not know
about that one
um so argue
um your side of the story so Bowser has
a really cool crib he has the Airship
Peach has her castle who has the cooler
crib and why oh
I feel like I'm chasing if I don't say
peach but I would say that it would be
fun to like have your house move around
with you
that's pretty great that's like a good
thing for like tarsals and horses it's
kind of cool that your home just goes
with you wherever you go
but I mean Peach's castle has the toads
and how can you pass out living amongst
like such a cute little population they
are they are so adorable
um and I know you wanted to take on this
role because this is a different version
of peach so what can you tease for fans
that are so excited to see about her
what do you think people are gonna be
surprised about and what sort of
surprised you about playing her I think
I was surprised at how inspiring I found
a character that I voiced has nothing to
do with my voice has nothing to do with
anything else it's the character itself
she's so tough so compassionate so kind
so on top of everything and she's
determined it comes from a place of Love
Like true love towards her people but
she's just not going to let anything
happen to them and by any means and I
think that determination is uh really
inspiring
[Music]
whatever those things are oh
we will destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
I think I've interviewed you like eight
or ten times and every time you either
do a hidden talent you do an impression
you sing you do something so I'm just
gonna put it out there Hit Me With Your
Best Shot Jack fire away what do you got
today have you ever seen this
I could do it all day
are you doing the reverse way no
um you know
I think you know all my my hidden skills
they're not so hidden
that's my warm-up
was that your warm-up for Bowser because
there's a lot of music in this film I
love that you went back to your heavy
metal roots
yes Bowser's on screen we get some metal
talk to me about that well there's an
obvious connection between Bowser and
Heavy Metal He's a fire breathing dragon
uh you know uh Gene Simmons comes to
mind of Kiss
um and all of the imagery of Bowser and
his ship that's you know like made of of
lava and fire and stone carved gargoyle
faces it's very heavy metal it's very
Metallica
and uh I was uh really thrilled to see
that they embraced that fully and that
they put some heavy metal into the movie
when you see Bowser occasionally they'd
be a little blast of of Hard Rock
I love it what do you think's on
Bowser's playlist Bowser definitely got
some Metallica on there yeah uh he's
also definitely got a little Slayer
um but he's also got a sensitive side so
there's probably some some power ballads
on there maybe a little scorpions maybe
a little bit of a uh who's some of the
softer ones that really could oh uh
Ronnie James Dio I always got to talk
about Ronnie James Dio he's my yeah
childhood hero greatest singer in the
history of rock and roll uh also a
little Black Sabbath Ozzy Osbourne you
gotta have some Ozzy on that playlist
and
um
I'm gonna mix it up with a little
Foreigner oh yeah I love a little
Foreigner um I know you're a gamer
you're obviously you know a lot about
this world what would you like to see in
a future installment I wonder if we're
getting a Bowser Jr and if you think you
could play Bowser Jr he's got to hire
intonation in his voice
Bowser Jr
wow I can't imagine that I would play a
a son of Bowser
but uh you never know never say never I
could they could pitch shift my voice
Lynn post right yeah um but uh what's
the future gosh that's a question for
the writers I don't know how how uh how
this story could Twist and Turn but I'm
I'm down to clown any which way they go
it was so much fun on this this
experience was there speaking of you we
were talking about your Airship for a
little bit who do you think has the
better crib do you think Princess Peach
has the better crib with her castle or
do you think the airship's cooler
I mean look the Airship is cooler if you
know
if you're if you're uh if you're a heavy
metal fan I guess it's a question of
taste true um the the castle is is also
pretty impressive but uh yeah there's
nothing can beat my craft
my craft just comes flying through space
definitely a warship for the for the
ages
I'm wondering because whenever we saw
him in the game whenever we see really
like comparing apples and peaches
there's apples and oranges what would it
be it would be peaches and like some
kind of devil fruit dragon fruit it's
like comparing dragon fruits and peaches
they're two totally different fruits
yours is Prickly
mine is Prickly and delicious like your
body in the film this is perfect let's
get a little personal
next question speaking of personal
prickly like your body in the film
of course I didn't mean you at all
you're a warm fuzzy person
um in the film about like whenever we
see Bowser he's always like ready to
fight what are Bowser's doing behind the
scenes to get ready for battle what is
he doing in in private
well Bowser spends a lot of time in the
weight room obviously he's a gym rat uh
he works the pecs he does a lot of uh a
lot of push-ups but he does uh he likes
to do granny push-ups
um and uh he does a lot of core work
he works uh interestingly he does a lot
of uh uh Pilates
spends a lot of time on the Cadillac
um and just uh spends a lot of time just
fire breathing just for practice he does
doesn't he but I love that softer side
that we do see of him so I'm just
wondering if he was to have a movie
night and invite all the uh the coop is
over what's he playing for everybody
what kind of movies do you think he's
watching weirdly his favorite movie is
uh You've Got Mail
that's a rom-com with Tom Hanks
uh yeah he he isn't a he's a softy when
it comes to when it comes to uh Cinema
he does he does like those love stories
he has a refined taste I like it
um if you could perhaps
hair Bowser in the game to the Bowser
we're gonna see in the film
um yeah if you could sort of like dive
into that a little bit he also loves
When Harry Met Sally
I'll have what she's having
uh sorry what was the next question no I
like where you're going with that
which one is Bowser playing the Harry or
the Sally in that in that obviously he's
the Harry he's the Harry oh I wanted him
to be the Sally
but what was the what was that other
question I got sidetracked by the
rom-coms
um your game how he compares to the
games in the film and what was your
favorite Nintendo game growing up my
favorite Nintendo game I was there at
the very beginning for Donkey Kong when
that came out in the early 80s I was
playing video games you know and I was
into it and I loved it I was obsessed
with it I played it every day after
school for years
but um
uh how does Bowser compare to the Bowser
in the video games I mean in most of the
the video games featuring Bowser he
doesn't say anything he's just Grunts
and groans I mean we got a fully fleshed
like character here he's got uh all
these insecurities and sensitivities and
the Romantic side and he's fully what
you'd expect he's evil he he lie cheat
and steal and he's greedy and he's
jealous
had lots of ton tons of Great Character
stuff to play can we go out with an ear
wiggle or an eyebrow race yep
you remain my favorite guy I gave you
the full arsenal you gave me everything
you got you Hit Me With Your Best Shot I
appreciate it and I love the T-shirt hit
you with my best shot
excuse me everybody
this guy's brother is going to die
imminently out of the way please just
trying to clear a path that's all I'm
doing he's gonna be fine now that I've
seen this movie I told you before that
toad was adorable and now I think he's
extra adorable I was smiling from ear to
ear every time he was on camera now he
does find a way to get himself into
every situation right like he sort of I
wouldn't say the third wheel but he
finds a way into all the action around
Princess Peach a lot so settle the score
for me is he secretly in love with
Princess Peach 100 yes
hundred percent yes he now but now now
he he has actually kind of split
allegiances it's it's really he's very
ambivalent now it's tearing him up
inside because he loves Mario so much
he wants to bro out with Mario so much
but he as he's holding a torch for peach
at the exact same time so it's really
there's a lot going on emotionally for
toad that that's a lot for you to you
know take
I thought maybe he was going to hold out
for Toadette but perhaps not no no I
mean he's not he really I'm telling you
here this is the scoop is that he's in
love with Princess Peach is he going to
end up with her do you think I you know
what listen if I have anything to do
with writing the next movie that's
exactly what's going to happen so you'll
see we'll see I love that I love that I
mean I won't I won't but no but I think
I think this is a great Avenue to go
down
um what I loved is when I was listening
to your
version of toad
you more than anybody else in the cast
I'm like Keegan was improvising for sure
because there was like a looseness about
the character is that true or do you
just make lines sound so free like they
were improvp or was there there was some
improv there was not as much as it
there's not as much I think there's not
as much as you think there was but um
but there was I think sometimes what
happens is when you get to improvise
lines
when you start to improvise and
improvise and improvise and then you go
into the regular line that naturalness
stays there and so that's kind of does
that make sense yeah I'm saying yeah so
then that naturalness you get to hear
that naturalness into the regular line
um I'm trying to and then there are
other lines to be quite honest with you
I don't remember if they were dialogue
or if I improvise them because it's
really very well written I think tone is
very well written and so there are times
where the lines just they felt good in
your mouth and so they don't they come
out naturally and um I'm trying to think
even in the trailer when I say oh uh
okay okay when Donkey Kong is beating up
Mario I can't remember if that's an
extra line or if that was in the
dialogue it's it's a it's a very
interesting question or if they take it
yeah from another piece of what you were
doing and are like let's throw it into
that scene yeah and sometimes yeah and
actually sometimes they do that they're
I mean they're brilliant they're Marvels
at this kind of stuff the editors it is
so good this film is so darn good it's
going to explode people are going to
love it um the last time we talked you
showed me how you got the toad voice how
you were going there and higher and
higher once you have the voice I want to
go a step further were you walking
around the house in the toad voice were
you singing in the toad voice
were you and did you play other Mario
characters in your preparation for fun
no um no I I tried to stick with
exclusively with toad okay so that any
any sounds that toad would make because
I still wanted to kind of reference any
of the sounds that he's emitted
throughout the years that we've heard
him doing you know what I mean yeah so I
wanted to make sure that was still
intact that at least so that we're
honoring the character but for me most
of the reason to stay in the voice was
you know just um
um pretend I'm sucking on helium just
pretend I'm sucking on helium and
wearing tight pants all the time so oh
that's that'll do it that'll make your
best that'll keep that'll keep you up
there you know
um so I read that you were a very
actually you were a huge Donkey Kong fan
growing up loved Donkey Kong that was my
game that was my favorite video game as
a kid and I used to go to the arcade and
play that game I only played two games I
played Dig Dug and Donkey Kong those
were my two games and then when we got a
console at home I was like oh my gosh I
get to play Donkey Kong all the time my
poor television was like bro you're
killing me what are you doing what are
you doing you got it you gotta stop but
I would just keep playing and playing
and playing I loved Donkey Kong I loved
Donkey Kong too yeah it was my favorite
game I loved it so much so um let's go
back to that if you were gonna write a
future future Chris is sort of set up
that this is the beginning of the
Nintendo Cinematic Universe what
Nintendo game would you like to see in a
future film you know who would be
interesting I think it would be
interesting if
we opened up like the Kirby world
you know what I mean I just like when
Kirby goes and sucks people you know
people into him to get abilities like
what would what would the reason that's
one thing I like is that you get to
start to justify why behaviors happen in
the universe or happen in the world like
what what is the reason that he sucks
like people and like things into him
like is it you know and is he from a
whole world of Kirby's like you know
it's that that kind of that question
mark comes up to my head in a big old
block that you can punch that coins will
come out of I think think you could play
I mean this is the thing you don't sound
like you in this film you can voice
other characters that's right that's
right I could if they listen whatever
they would like me to do I'm game you're
down for it I am okay you might get this
question a lot but I'm going to ask it
if key and peel were dropped into the
Mario Universe into the Mushroom Kingdom
what would a sketch possibly look like
between the two of them what would a
sketch possibly look like I think what
it would probably be it might be you
know because one of our uh our expertise
on key and peel is doing name sketches
you know sketches with names in it is is
to think of all of the different names
of people and we talk we do this a
little bit in the movie the different
names of mushrooms you know what I mean
like what you would name the different
measures what's going on chanterelle
how you doing Morel you good okay good
to see you where's head of the Woods at
uh with my boy and then you know they're
like you know like a rapper who would be
a rapper in the Metro Kingdom King
oyster
you know what I'm talking about I know
just name all the different mushrooms
you know and see and see how you could
figure out like is was there is there a
band where all the members of the band
are mushroom something like that I gotta
think about that what do you think is on
Toad's playlist
what is on Toad's playlist
um lots of psychedelic music you know it
has to be I mean what are we talking
about if you eat a mushroom and it makes
you bigger what kind of mushrooms are we
talking about right you know what I mean
so lots of Jefferson Starship Jimi
Hendrix you know what I mean Strawberry
Alarm Clock
uh Iron Butterfly good like good like
you know psychedelic music I love this
so I love the direction that we're going
with all this um if you can without
spoilers you do kind of grow out a
little bit with Mario in this film can
you talk about maybe a scene sort of
breakdown maybe watching it back as a
fan
your sort of favorite moment for toad in
this film well I think one of my
favorite moments for toad is the very
first moment that he experiences Mario
because you see how up for showing him
his world he is the other thing I have
to remember is the very first thing toad
does is protect Mario the very first
thing he does so it's foreshadowing for
the rest of the movie about how he feels
about Mario is that he tells him not to
eat that mushroom and that and that it
it'll harm him or that'll die and so it
shows you what kind of what kind of
being toad is that he cares you know and
when I watch that back I think about
that and I go oh my God I didn't I never
thought of that before but look at how
much she cares because I'm so
in the performance of it I was so
shocked you know what I mean like you
know don't get away from that mushroom
but when you think about I think back I
go he's like he's a hero you know
he's made of he's made of good stuff
well he's a protagonist in some of the
games so maybe in a future film coming
to a theater near you I think there
should be a Mushroom Kingdom game
Mushroom Kingdom movie I'm just saying
that I'm looking at the publicist for
Universal
and now I'm looking back at you